so we have an example today of something
i've been talking about with you guys
for a long time
one of the hallmarks of conspiratorial
thinking
is that finding apparent evidence is of
course
evidence of the conspiracy a conspiracy
theory
but not finding evidence is also
evidence of the conspiracy because it
means that
they covered up the evidence the
evidence has been destroyed
the evidence has been suppressed and so
there's really no way out of these
conspiracy thinking situations we now
have an example of this from the world
of covid's conspiracies you really have
to see this
uh the tick tock channel the good liars
interviewed a woman
who claims that her friend who
supposedly died of covid which is a
tragedy
was actually medically abducted
and killed so that the hospital could
get fifty thousand dollars for treating
a fake
covet patient this is a woman who has a
friend
the friend tragically got the virus and
died
that's evidence that her conspiracy
about covid being
a hoax is wrong it would seem as though
the evidence disproves
the covet hoax conspiracy that this
woman believes
nope the fact that her friend died of
covid
becomes part of the conspiracy the
evidence was faked
she was abducted her friend didn't
really die
of covid so let's look at the full clip
once then we're going to look back at
some individual pieces because
there's just so much here another friend
of mine she actually was
medically kidnapped they did it to get
the money for fifty thousand dollars
because if you say you have covered you
get fifty thousand dollars the hospitals
but she
died of covet in the hospital they
killed her but she was she she tested
positive for coveted no she was just she
got she had she just passed out because
she was weak this one day i have a
picture of her they have her mouth and
they have her sedated they have her on
that ventilator
okay so of course this is all horribly
tragic
a death from covet is tragic but also
this woman believing that this is what
happened is
is tragic as well so let's dig into just
how much stuff is wrong
about what she says because it's
actually remarkable how much is squeezed
into just 21 seconds here let's look at
the first bit again
another friend of mine she actually was
medically kidnapped they did it to get
the money for fifty thousand dollars
because if you say you have covered you
get fifty thousand dollars the hospital
okay so there's this idea if a hospital
says someone has covered
they get 50 000 for treating them
this all goes back to when medicare
rates were established for covid19
patients
who don't need to be put on a ventilator
and who do need to be put on a
ventilator
it turned out that the reimbursement
rates for medicare patients were a
little bit higher
uh than for non-covered hospitalizations
there's a reason for that and there's
also no evidence whatsoever of
fraudulent reporting and
the other funny thing is the num the the
numbers started at 35 000 for covid
patients
now that apparently wasn't wacky enough
so now they go to
it's 50 000 for a covid patient medicare
establishes reimbursement rates for
treatment it is true
that if a patient goes on a ventilator
medicare reimburses more than if they
don't because they're providing more
services
it is true that for covid patients on
ventilators
medicare reimburses a little bit more
because remember the way health
insurance works is on
averages on average it is more expensive
to treat the coveted patient that is on
a ventilator
now we can have an argument about how
our medical system works
how it works where doctors and hospitals
get paid for each thing
that they do rather than simply for
keeping people healthy or making people
healthy
that's all fine but the issue here is
hospitals don't just get cash for
claiming people
have a covid and there is no evidence
whatsoever that hospitals are lying
about it there is no evidence hospitals
are lying about it they are simply being
compensated
based on the services that they provide
this is really
nutty stuff let's look at the rest of it
but she
died of covet in the hospital she didn't
dive covered they killed her but she was
she she tested positive for covet no she
was just she got
she just passed out because she was weak
this one day i have a picture of her
they have her mouth and they have her
sedated
they have her on that ventilator imagine
that story
her friend was fine and then one day her
friend passes out because
she was weak that day it was just a
weekday the friend passed out nothing
was wrong with her just a weekday
and in swoops a hospital abducts her
reports her as having covid to get the
50k
and then kills her and this brings me to
one other aspect of this that's really
really wild
you don't need the patient to die to get
paid
if you treat them at the hospital you
get paid for the treatment you provide
you don't get more money because they
die
and the conspiracy theorist would say
well no david
please the reason you have to kill them
is because otherwise they could go and
say i didn't really have covid they
kidnapped me or whatever
but now there's a new conspiracy right
you're adding layers of complexity to
the conspiracy
that was another wacky part of it uh
this is serious illness i'm talking
about what the woman that that survived
has that is serious illness
and unfortunately how on earth do you
talk sense into someone like that
you know there are some conspiracy
theorists that when you talk to them
you sort of get the feeling maybe i'd be
able to talk some sense into them we
might be able to have
like a real conversation and over time
they might be able to be
disabused and deprogrammed of these
beliefs
i don't know how you could with this
woman i really don't
and of course the idea of hospitals
over counting for cash happens to be
something trump floated in 2020.
trump talked about hospitals are lying
about this to make money
so there's always some trump connection
and certainly i would assume
that this woman voted for donald trump
this is really bad stuff this is
to call it weaponized delusions uh
i don't think goes far enough and i
don't know how we deal with that if you
have any ideas let me know
if your job requires you to know what
people are talking about
online or you're just curious what's
being discussed online
check out thought leaders which has an
awesome
data platform that scrapes through
youtube
podcasts newsletters every day and
analyzes what is in the content
and then they turn that data into
customizable graphs whether that's a
brand a person a topic anything else you
want to explore
companies can see where their
competitors have been mentioned
marketers can see what trends are on the
rise before planning strategy
or content creators like me can see what
topics and themes
are being featured on other shows for
example you can see here
i can track what podcasts are discussing
the midterm elections or i can see how
many youtube channels are talking about
rudy giuliani or i can even see what
shows have mentioned
me by searching my own name and you can
use this
for free that's free forever
sign up today create your own instant
thought leaders trends report now
the link is down below